[Applause]
for a second successive day
people in myanmar have taken to the
streets to protest against the military
takeover
marching through downtown yangon they
held up a three-finger salute
a symbol of defiance against
authoritarian rule
even people who weren't part of the
demonstration showed their support by
clapping
or honking their cars protesters are
demanding an end to military rule
and the release of aung san tsuji the
democratically elected leader
and others still in custody they marched
undeterred by the police presence and
the threat of arrest
we have decided we will fight until the
end of our lives for our generation
we have to work for the next generation
to get democracy for them
if we want to end this military
dictatorship myanmar emerged from nearly
50 years of military rule
in 2011. people here are aware of the
military's brutal repression of past
uprisings
but some say they're not afraid
our ancestors had already made
revolution against the military
we can't just let the military win
citizens had already shown their demands
by voting we are on the streets to show
that we are against the military
dictatorship
a near total shutdown of the internet
and disruption of phone lines
was partially lifted on sunday facebook
and other social media platforms had
already been blocked
the un special rapporteur on myanmar has
accused
the military of trying to paralyze the
movement of resistance
and keep the outside world in the dark
all week
the voice of disquiet has grown louder
and bolder
from nightly noise protests in yangon to
a civil disobedience campaign
the u.n secretary general antonio
guterres has pledged the u.n will do all
it can
to unite the international community and
create conditions for the coup to be
reversed
activists say mere words are unlikely to
have any impact
the military leadersh dictatorship is
gambling on the fact that there will be
a lot of statements but no real action
it's time to target military companies
because
the economics of the situation is
economic power is
one of the motivating forces for the
military to grab
power like this for now there's no sign
the generals are ready to give up
control
even though the calls for them to go are
growing
sunday's demonstrations are the largest
since a 2007 uprising against the
military florence louis
al jazeera